i'm at windsor castle where prince harry
and megan Markel will get married next
weekend 8 days and Counting their
families will meet before the big day we
expect a massive celebration Charlie
d'Agata met some of the soldiers who
served with Harry in the military and
will be by his side on his wedding day
he joins us from outside Windsor Castle
with more on the story here is Charlie
daggers report good morning well we've
learned from palace officials that when
Megan Markos family arrives next week
they intend on spending some quality
time with the Queen and the entire royal
family in fact Her Majesty just happens
to be here today at the wedding venue
Windsor Castle the oldest inhabited
castle in the world is getting ready to
welcome its newest royal on the morning
of the wedding Megan's mother Dorio will
travel with her daughter by car to
Windsor Castle and her father Thomas
will walk Megan down the aisle but it's
not just the family of the bride were
delighted to be taking part obviously
mom yes and I'm sure to be a very
special day everybody and every royal
love in marriage needs a horse and
carriage while they were getting ready
to roll we had a behind-the-scenes look
at the famous household cavalry
a regiment close to Harry's heart that
will have a special mission on wedding
day but pomp and pageantry is only one
part of what they do best they're also
an elite fighting force serving on the
frontlines of Iraq and Afghanistan where
Prince Harry served two tours
corporal Frankie O'Leary was Harry's
radio operator in Afghanistan he says
more than a soldier Harry was one of the
lads he's a British Gordie Howe
we'd live off we live up moaning poor
food and says a human that's what we do
having fought beside Harry on the
battlefield O'Leary will now flank his
friend once more on that ride to Windsor
Castle captain Tom Mountain will also be
there whose nerves of steel stretch
beyond the battlefield essentially it
makes no difference how many people are
watching really we will continue you and
go about our our duties and our part of
the parade no matter whether it's one
[Laughter]
well we'll certainly be watching now
Megan Marco will arrive here at Windsor
the night before the wedding I could
tell you the entire town is getting
ready for a party and of course
everybody was looking forward to seeing
you cow yeah
well listen I'm looking forward to going
Charlie d'Agata at Windsor Castle thanks
a lot you know I've been thinking about
as I'm watching Prince Harry whether he
will keep his beard or shave it for the
wedding and I say that he will keep his
beard for the wedding you do I think
he's gonna shave it want to make a bed
well I have heard that she likes it so
I'm thinking he's going to keep it what
do you say now Nora what do you say now
you know more than I do and I don't know
yes let's make a bet well there's the
question of will he but then should he
do we have an opinion on that think
about it your picture that you have you
know your wedding picture forever I
don't know but I think you direction
what's our bet you know it's good either
way what's our bed what's our bet mine
Oh what are we betting yes but he
doesn't house it yeah but how much yeah
I'm talking about money with the other
ones yes I'm talking about money yeah
hundred bucks favorite charity please
make it 500 to your favorite charity
because it's going to charity nor cuz
it's going to charity
yes I got three children alright alright
alright
it is 500 bucks to remind me never to
beg a little I am NOT taking her to
Vegas if it was going to us I would say
100 but you said cheering okay let's do
it I said $500 all right out of this
conversation I was thinking like a
nickel no $500 our live coverage of the
wedding starts at 4:00 a.m. on Saturday
please let me win may 19th runs until
10:00 a.m. that's right here on CBS